hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast reference component analysis
of single-cell transcriptomes reveals
cellular heterogeneity and colorectal
cancer I am Robert Castellanos of lab
rats and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
a fluid eye fluid ein crates and
manufacture innovative technologies and
life science tools designed to
revolutionize biology through relentless
pursuit of scientific truth its core
technologies are based on micro fluidics
and massive tama trained and enabled the
exploration and analysis of single cells
as well as industrial application of
genomics for more information please
visit fluid I'm calm we have a few an
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as time
allows you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem
through the green Q&A button lower left
this is an educational webinar and this
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the C button located at the bottom
left corner of your webpage and follow
the process of obtaining your credits I
would like to now introduce today's
speaker dr. Shyam Prabhakar dr.
Prabhakar obtained a BTech in
electronics and communications
engineering from IIT Madras and a PhD in
Applied Physics from Stanford University
he is a sole recipient of the 2001
American Physical Society thesis award
in being physics
as a postdoctoral fellow under Eddie
Ruben at the Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratory
he led seminal studies of human
evolution through gene regulatory
changes in 2007 he joined the genome
Institute of Singapore where his group
uses single-cell RNA sequence cohorts
kale chips rican and other
high-throughput assays to uncover
molecular mechanisms and diagnostic or
prognostic markers of human diseases and
paralleled the group develops
computational algorithms for deriving
biological insights from functional
genomics data I'd like to introduce the
doctor now for his presentation
ok so specifically what we want to
understand in colorectal cancer is into
a tumor heterogeneity now intellectual
heterogeneity can take many forms
you could have genetic heterogeneity
where the DNA sequences are different
because of somatic mutations from cell
to cell within the same tumor and that
has been relatively well studied though
there's a long way to go using single
cell genome sequencing single cell DNA
sequencing but then this functional
heterogeneity which for examples some
cells may be most stem like in the tumor
stem cells may be less stem like or
there could be micro environment
heterogeneity where the stromal cells
could have different properties within
the same tumor and actually across
tumors also so this functional
heterogeneity within tumors has
traditionally been addressed using same
marker based sorting so you use cancer
stem cell marker for example to purify
that sub population but one limitation
of that is you need to know what you're
looking for already micro environment
Etra gennadius again been used has been
studied using bulk transcriptomics where
again you either purify populations or
you mash up the whole tumor and
characterize the functional states of
transcriptomic states again I would say
there's two limitations of both these
approaches which is that either you're
looking at the whole tier on Ultima
which is a very
ah genius pool of cells and so you
mixing the signals of the different cell
types oh you're trying to pull out what
you think is a pure cell population but
then you don't know which marker to use
and then you really bias we only find
what you're looking for in some cases so
we believe quite a few years ago that
the way to go here was single-cell
transcriptomics where it would be
unbiased we would just take all the
cells in the tumor and profile a one
cell at a time and profile the
transcriptomes and then try to figure
out put all of the pieces together by
informatica li so that's our approach
and single cell transit omics is very
promising there's already been two great
papers in this field for solid tumors
from Aviv Regev group and the idea is
that you can do unbiased de novo
identification of tumor cell types right
without any prior assumptions and
thereby understand you know in a
panoramic way so to speak
functional heterogeneity in a tumor
having done that you can identify new
biomarkers potentially and also stratify
patients essentially you have a more
powerful microscope to look at the tumor
and thereby to look at the patient and
that should lead to better patient
stratification that you can get bump
from bulk tumor analysis I should say
also right now patients are already
stratified based on their genetic
mutations in the tumors we really hope
that it should be possible and I'll show
you some results there that they could
be stratified based on the single-cell
transcriptomes as well then you can find
our cell new cell type markers and then
do the more shall we say biased analysis
where you already know which cell type
they're looking for but the cell type
we're looking for is really discovered
using single-cell transcriptomics and we
can also ask basic biological questions
about epithelial tumors for example are
they undergoing epithelial-mesenchymal
transition and if so you should be able
to see that in the transcriptome are we
seeing cancer stem cells
is there just one discrete stem cell
population was there continuum of SEM
stemness as some recent studies have
shown and then maybe discover cell types
that were never known before at all so
these are like you know cryptic species
in the cryptic cell types where there's
subtly different so and they have the
same normal fax marker but they actually
they have different functional
properties and different phenotypes
again we should be able to identify that
by informatica ly from all this so
that's why this field is exciting and
that's why we got into it it's also
challenging it's not straightforward but
methods improving I'm saying so one
challenge for epithelial tumors is that
cells stick together and they don't like
to be dissociated I'm using the analogy
to the Corleone's family like any good
Mafia family they're very close-knit and
they stick together but then when Fredo
dissociates from the family goes up to
Vegas that's behaving weirdly and then
eventually it gets killed and that's
what happens to epithelial cells if you
dissociate them so they change their
behavior and so you really have to be
careful how you handle them single-cell
transcriptomics or any single cell
assays noisy we're measuring a smaller
number of molecules so that's something
to be aware of and it's not just noisy
noise can be settled or noise can be
combatted by averaging a lot of data
sets
there's also technical bias from cell to
cell and I'll show you what that does to
your conclusions in a minute and finally
it is more expensive than Bob
transcriptomics because you need to do
many cells so how do you address all
these challenges firstly in our lab we
use a custom dissociation protocol
that's relatively gentle and hopefully
does not perturb the cells too much or
cause them to die too quickly
I'll show you new algorithms we're
developing to fight noise and bias and
the cost is continuously dropping as
technology speed up and scale up so so
that's very promising so start with the
algorithms we've
which is intelligent not cancer specific
but really if you want to get into this
field and you want to learn something
from single-cell transcriptomic data I
would argue you need algorithms that are
custom developed for single-cell
analysis as I'll show the standard bulk
algorithms don't always work because
single-cell data look very different
from bulk data so the three algorithms
you will need to do this product tumor
analysis or perhaps a nice complex
tissue analysis using single cell
transit omics are firstly normalization
you need to normalize the cells against
each other so you can compare them then
having normalized the data you need to
cluster the cells I'm showing a cell
cell similarity heat map you can see
these little squares or red squares are
presumably cell types they're plug
groups of cells that look like each
other and the transcriptomic level and
presumably they're the same cell type
but that's again challenging as I'll
show you need an algorithm for that and
then having identified cell types by
informatica Li you want to be able to
differentiate between two different cell
types and say which gene is upregulated
in the cell type of genus downregulated
in the cell type and you need a separate
algorithm for that as well so why new
normalization method for starters
there's well-known balcony seek
normalization methods the main problem
is with those methods is that they
design for data that looked like bug
data and this is what they look like
what I'm showing here is six
superimposed balcony seek data sets from
two time points and it's this is the
distribution of expression values okay
so x-axis is expression log expression
you can see and you can see there's very
few cells or sorry very few genes at the
high end with 10 raised to 5 10 raise to
6 expression and most genes are around
10 raised to 2 to 10 raised to 3
expression and this distribution is
really uniform across the six sample
types so the distributions land on top
of each other so almost any bulk
normalization method
we'll work on data that look like this
it's not too hard this is what single
cell data look like you have
superimposed six single cell
transcriptomes as you can see here the
expression distributions are very
different and it's dodged simply a
matter of cell cycle variability genuine
biological variable variability between
the cells because we see this pattern
even in post mitotic cells so something
is going on and so we really need a bug
while trance economic normalization
method will only shift these curves
around it won't make and look like each
other so that is a challenge and you
could get false positives another issue
is that you don't detect very many genes
so compared to balcony second balcony
seek you detect ten thousand-plus or ten
thousand fifteen thousand genes in one
data set single cell on EC gives you
only a few thousand genes and the worst
case sometimes if you have a tumor
sample has been sitting on the in the
hospital for a long time before it gets
to you you could detect only a thousand
or eight hundred genes so most genes
have a zero detected expression value
and that again confuses conventional
methods so what's our approach we
developed a method called PQ
normalization and we even built on that
further but today I'll just talk about
PQ normalization its pseudo counted
quantile normalization very simple
starts with classical quantile
normalization which takes these very
different-looking
expression distributions and normalizes
them so now they all look the same right
and that's a transcript that's the
transformation you want to affect
there's still a problem each cell has a
different number of zeros because each
cell has a different quality of data and
that's where the pseudo count comes in
we use not an expression to the count
but a rank based pseudo count and I
don't have time to get into why that's
useful but that's really critical to
allow you to compare sales across each
other now as I'll show you this pseudo
count really gets you better performance
than normal quantile normalization so
here's one way of benchmarking it and I
should say for all our algorithms
we do benchmarking we we don't just use
developed algorithms and and run it we
use independent benchmarks before we
apply to tumor data so here we are
benchmarking our single-cell
normalization by applying it to six
different single cell on ECG data sets
the one in the middle the mouse brain we
generated ourselves and the others were
downloaded from published papers each
bar represents the amount of technical
bias in your after normalization right
so you want the technical bias to be
very small and so you want that bar to
be very low after normalization as you
can see the black bar PQ normalization
gives you the lowest technical bias of
all and the others you might recognize
some of the other normalization methods
that are widely used so that's great you
want to minimize technical variation in
your data set another benchmark is how
good are your differential expression
cause you know after normalizing if you
normalize well you'll get accurate
differential expression cause if you
normalize badly your differential
expression calls will not be very good
in the way we benchmark that is we took
corresponding balcony C data found
differentially expressed genes and said
can we recapitulate those d genes in the
single cell data and that gives us a way
of benchmarking accuracy for the y axis
here as accuracy you can see here again
the p PQ normalization is the most
accurate at finding differential
expression express genes from single
cell data and here it clearly
outperforms quantile normalization
traditional content normalization on the
patel data set and the treadmill dataset
and those are data sets where the number
of undetected genes is very different
between cell type a and cell type B and
that's where you need the rank me a
pseudo count the third way we
benchmarked it was we said let's apply
to a complex data from a complex tissue
mouse brain in this case because we want
to analyze colorectal tumors and that's
quite complex too so we dissociated
cells from mouse brain and I think we
did about
600 any single cell on e6 perhaps more
now in this heat map you see that each
column is a cell and each row is a
marker culled from the literature so
you've got a suicide markers in your
other markers oligodendrocyte markers
and so on now from the heat map you can
see that if you know the markers you can
tell the cell types apart very nicely
and we got all the major brain cell
types here but often you don't know the
markers in advance and we want our
algorithms to work so well that they can
cluster the cells without knowing the
markers in advance so which
normalization method gives you the best
clustering and here's what that looks
like so each row here is one
normalization method and the top few
rows are all the popular balcony seek
normalization methods the last row is PQ
normalization and each dot is a cell and
cells of the same type have the same
color so you can see that the most
normalization methods do a decent job of
helping you cluster cells by type but
you see long streets in these PCA plots
for many normalization methods and those
streaks are essentially technical
variation they're not biological as far
as we know only PQ normalization in to
some extent you normalization but mainly
PP normalization causes the cells to
clump together very cleanly by cell type
and you don't see these long streaks
anymore cause it's really minimized
technical variation so by three
benchmarks PT normalization seems to be
superior to conventional normalization
methods and that's because it's
specifically tailored to single-cell RNA
seek data so that's the first algorithm
you want next you want a clustering
algorithm but I'll talk about the
differential expression algorithm first
cuz that's published together with the
PQ normalization and is by our Chi paper
so this is called nodes and the key
thing to remember about nodes is that is
that it's a nonparametric method and the
reason we opted for a nonparametric
method was a nonparametric methods make
very few assumptions about the data what
we found is that more or less any
parametric assumption you may
about single surah nisa data whether
it's log normal or negative binomial or
zero and plaited negative binomial ends
up being violated by single cell data to
some extent because of technical
variability and actually nonparametric
methods are just as powerful as
parametric methods when you have a large
number of data sets which of course is
the case you have large number of cells
in single any single cell data set so
there's no downside to using
nonparametric methods and I would argue
there's a huge upside in the sense that
your statistics of p-values are not
distorted by deviations of the data from
your assumptions so the other advantage
of nonparametric methods is that they
are relatively quick you don't need to
do parameter estimation optimization and
so first so yeah I actually just
summarized these bullet points let me
get to the statistics we use
specifically in nodes we use a combined
statistic which is the tip shirani D
statistic and also the wilcoxon test
statistic which is again and these are
two nonparametric statistics for
identifying differential genes what we
found is that one of them works well one
of them doesn't but when you combine
them using Fisher's method into one
statistic you do really well and you get
actually very accurate okay I shouldn't
say very I could quite accurate
differential expression Falls and I'll
show you how that works in a moment so
first I'll show you the speed of the
algorithm
so here the x-axis is the number of
cells we processed y-axis is how much
time it took on a conventional desktop
computer you can see here it takes a few
minutes so nodes takes a few minutes
even when you go beyond a thousand cells
whereas a methods that are device for
balcony seek they they don't they don't
scale very well right they they can take
up to an hour or they can
or even more or they run out of memory
and that's a challenge so you know they
take a lot of memory and they're slow so
that's a speed advantage and I'd say the
scalability an advantage which is very
important because new technologies are
spitting out thousands of single-cell
RNC datasets in one run now you want
something that's capable and fast and
then this performance so here you can
see how accurate the differentially
expressed gene calls are by nodes and by
a bunch of other D callers a bunch of
other statistics that are widely used I
should say here to make a fair
comparison
we used PQ normalization for all of
these for all of these de callers and
then called and the only difference was
that the D caller was different actually
I'm sorry I think we used a trend mean
of M values here for all the methods so
yeah so nodes to summarize nodes is
faster and also gives better performance
on all of these benchmark data sets so
finally you want an algorithm for
clustering single cella transcriptomes
and then you're ready to go you're ready
to analyze solid tumor data now before
getting into that we thought we would
first benchmark existing methods and for
that what we did is we did single cell
Arnie sequin on about seven cell lines
for all seven we we did the same
normalization and then we decide we
cluster the cells by various methods you
can see a PCA plot which is not what we
actually used to cluster the cells
always but it gives you an illustration
of the performance so this is
conventional hierarchical clustering the
equivalent of that in a PCA plot each
dot is a cell each color as a cell cell
line and dots cluster by color
reasonably well but you can see here
there's a lot of mixing as well on at
the left edge of this PCA plot the
different cell lines are mixed too
that's not good also you can see here in
the black dotted circles you have two
batches of the same cell type separating
out very clearly in your PCA plot and in
your clustering dendrogram eventually so
that's a serious problem batch effects
in batch effects and cell lines are
going to confound your clustering then
for sure batch effects and your clinical
samples are going to confound your
clustering and so that was a serious
concern for us so we said let's use
another popular method which is to use
PCA itself to reduce the dimensionality
of the data projected onto the high
loading genes and then cluster the cells
again you see the you know you get
reasonable clustering but there's a lot
of mixing of cell types and again you
see native batch effects we also use the
backspin algorithm which is a single
cell specific clustering algorithm again
batch effects and mixing of cell types
we tried the race idea algorithm again
same thing we saw batch effects and mix
mixing of cell types and we presume of
that this is because there is profound
technical variability even in cell line
data which are relatively good quality
and so for sure you'll get this kind of
variability in primary tissue samples
which would tend to be of slightly lower
quality now below have shown the
clustering dendrogram equivalence for
all these clustering methods and again
each here each row is a single cell you
can see here they're the cells cluster
by color but then there is some mixing
as you can see visually in the PCA plots
as well so we really need a new
algorithm for clustering single cells
that's relatively resistant you can't
ever weed it up perfectly but relatively
resistant to batch effects and
relatively efficient at clustering cells
together by type and not mixing them and
so that's what we did we developed an
algorithm called RCA which stands for
reference component analysis the key
advantage of RCA or conventional methods
is that RCA uses more information than
just the information in your data set
self are see also uses information from
public databases of bulk transcriptomes
and looks at a variability in those
baoshan symptoms across cell types and
tissue types and use that to guide the
clustering so it's still an unsupervised
clustering but with external information
and as you can see from the PCA plot as
well as the dendogram now cells are
clustered almost perfectly by cell type
and there's no batch effect so the cells
from two different batches are exactly
on top of each other in the PCA plot and
perfectly intermingled in the dander
clustering dendogram so with these three
algorithms in hand for normalization
plus training differential expression we
had the confidence to go ahead and look
at primary tissue samples so here's a
single cell Nashik workflow for solid
tumors we started with resected primary
tumors colorectal cancer came to us and
we gently dissociated them as you can
see there's still plumps of tissue after
dissociation and there's debris as well
so all of that needs to be addressed
then we sometimes we FAC sort the cells
to purify single cells by their size
shape parameters and lightly separate
live cells from dead cells as well we
don't usually do that right now because
what we find is a fax stresses the cells
and we already steps stressed out from
ischemia for a long time and so we
didn't want to stress them any further
so generally we just take the cells you
know the facts are without facts more
often load them onto the c1 chip so I'm
showing here an image of the fluid I'm
see one instrument which some of you may
be familiar with so all of the data
generated here was done using the 96
cell microfluidic chip and you can see
an image of that on the right hand side
that's one capture chamber on this
microfluidic chip and you see the white
dot there in the middle is a single cell
captured in this chamber the big
advantage for us of this pipeline is
we can of this platform I should say is
that we can image each capture chamber
and say is this a single cell is this an
empty chamber is it debris is it a
doublet and so on
take notes and then sort them out later
so we're only looking at single cells
and I should say this is absolutely
crucial for us the imaging part because
we don't want say an epithelial cells
sticking to them as in Klieman cell and
forming a doublet and then it's
transcriptome will look like a mixture
of the two and we'll say AHA we've seen
at the Teelin mesenchymal transition but
actually just a doublet artifact or
maybe there's debris from a mesenchymal
cell sitting in the chamber you want to
know all that and that's why we you know
we use we use imaging very carefully
always and all that human samples and
then the cells are lysed in the
microfluidic chambers they DNA are sorry
the RNA is reverse transcribed then cDNA
is pre amplified it's dumped into a
96-well plate and then you do the
library library prep offline and then
you've got your libraries you got your
96 from each of you about 96 single-cell
RNA seek libraries ready for sequencing
take the sequencer and then map the
reads and goes to our server a compute
server and then we do all of the by
informatics that I just described the
algorithms for so that's a whole
workflow here's a dataset we had so this
is our initial data set where of course
scaling up but what I'll show you today
is from 11 patients or 11 resected
primary tumors and in seven of those
cases we also had nearby normal tissue
the nearby mucosa which you know bit
distant from the tumor for comparison
and if we added up all of the tumor and
normal samples we had about 1,600
single-cell RNA seek data sets we had a
very stringent QC
well okay first I should say we this is
unbiased we're looking at tumor-normal
and within the tumor and within the
normal we're looking at all of the cell
types you're not purifying any because
we really want to understand the cancer
cells and their ecosystem so as I said
we did very stringent QC on these cells
because they've been ischemic for a
while and so you don't want to analyze
all of them any of these cells are dying
so after QC we were left with around 600
single-cell RNA see datasets tumor
normal all of the cell types and for QC
we looked we used the number of mapped
reads and also the percent of my feeds
that are exonic and those are our
filtering criteria alright also we use
the number of detected genes as a filter
so okay can we what can we learn from
these cells of course we normalized the
data using PT normalization and then the
first thing we did was clustering
because we've destroyed the cells we
don't know even which cell type it is a
priority we need to buy informatics to
tell us which cell type it is and we
need the bioinformatics to cluster cells
by cell type so you can see here first
we started by clustering cells from the
normal normal tissue each row is the
cell each column is an expression
signature you can see here these cells
cluster quite nicely you can visually
see the clustering the science cells in
the top segment are epithelial cells
just below that the red cells in the
fibroblasts to me the main thing to note
here is that the science has the D
differentiated same stem like cells make
up the majority of the population and
which is which is what you would expect
if if you look in a tumor the science
says well actually a minority in the
normal tissue which is again expected so
I should stop you and point out that
already you can see here that if you do
bulk transcriptomics and if you do by
transfer
comics if and you have different cell
proportions then you could get
confounding right so if your stem like
cells are more abundant all of their
markers will come up in your bulk to
children by tumor transcriptome and you
think that all of those markers were
upregulated but that's not true it's
only that that cell type itself is more
abundant and that's again a major reason
why we we like to do single cell
transcriptomics so that we don't get
confining from cell type abundance okay
so I don't know if you thought the last
thing I was saying but if your cell type
proportions change then you could get
artificial differential expression and
that's a major concern so then the next
question we asked was are we seeing
epithelial mesenchymal transition so we
decided to write dye right into it the
background is that there have been some
studies recently saying a epithelial
mesenchymal transition is not necessary
for metastasis at least in a couple of
mouse models in fact the metastatic
cells don't seem to have ever ever
undergone epithelial mesenchymal
transition and secondly there's also a
study showing that it's the fibroblasts
a published not too long about showing
that it's a fibroblast cinder :
tumor that expressed the EMT genes
rather than the epithelial cells so
that's a backdrop and we said let's look
in our own data so in this heat map you
see here each row is an EMT marker but
in teen marker I mean really mesenchymal
markers you know twist
Zeb's nail all these mesenchymal
transition and transcription factors
that should come on in epithelial cells
when they undergo this transition to a
mesenchymal state and presumably at
least the theory is that that allows
them to detach from each other because
epithelial cells don't like to detach
and then it allows them to migrate to a
different site and form a metastatic
site metastatic tumor so over here as I
said each column is a cell and
the blue cells the dark blue bar at the
top indicates epithelial cells so the
upper heat map is normal low heat map is
colon tumor you can see here that the
epithelial cells don't seem to
upregulate EMT markers and see if I can
indicate that here so so this is the
zone you're looking at here you can see
empty markers are not very well
expressed in the normal epithelial cells
they're not very well expressed in the
tumor epithelial cells either right so
they're not up regulated on the contrary
you see here that it's the fibroblasts
in the tumor the caps the cancer
associated fibroblasts that are really
up regulating these mesenchymal markers
relative to normal fibroblasts and
that's consistent with the recent study
showing the same conclusion only here we
show it directly using single cell army
seek on a primary tumor we decided to
quantify this observation because as you
can see here it's visual was not
quantitative so we give each cell an EMT
score which is basically just we took
the average of have normalized average
expression of the mesenchymal markers
for each cell the blue dots here are the
epithelial cells and here you see that
there's normal epithelial cells over
here on the left so I'm just circling
the normal epithelial cells and I'm
circling the normal fibroblasts so you
can see here the fibroblast cell normal
fibroblast amazing common already so
they acquire EMT scores and then the
tumor epithelial cells which I can just
draw a line through here have about the
same EMT score as normal epithelial
cells but the tomb of fiberglass have
statistically significant up regulation
of of these EMT markers so this is
precisely what the previous study showed
as well that the EMT signal that you get
in your bug tumour transcriptome is
actually coming from the fibroblasts
it's not coming from the epithelial
cells we can't rule out of course
that there's you know one or two percent
of epithelial cells that are expressing
that are going through EMT but we do
believe that if the you know a large
fraction of epithelial cells were
undergoing empty we would see it now one
could worry of course that this one
could be concerned that these epithelial
cells what we are calling fibroblasts
are actually epithelial cells they've
changed the transcriptome so completely
that they fool you know we have fooled
into thinking they're fiberglass right
but the epithelial cells that underwent
EMT so to guard against that we did
exome sequencing on the same tumors on
both tumor identify the somatic variants
and then went back to the single-cell
RNA seek reads from these cells and said
okay do we detect those same somatic
variants if the overlap and exon do we
detect them and a single-cell RNA seek
data so what you see in this contingency
table is 2x2 table on the right hand
side is that of the five caps we looked
at this is not a large number but none
of the caps that we looked at had
somatic variants in there only the
epithelial cells had detectable somatic
variants in there are any secrets so
this gives us confidence I mean it's not
a large statistical sample but it's
still consistent with our annotations
being correct of epithelial and
fibroblast and so here I'm just citing
the paper that I had referred to before
studies consistent with their work
saying that it's a fiberglass are giving
the EMT signature this is quite
different from in vitro studies of
cancer cells where when you culture them
in vitro they do seem to have a genuine
mesenchymal phenotype so perhaps this is
a distinction between what's happening
in the primary tumor and what's
happening in cell culture we also one
could also worry that this is an
artifact of our processing once you
dissociate the tumors after resection so
on something different happens and you
lose that EMT signature but we use some
markers and add one I won't show the
data right here to validate these
finding the CMT findings in tissue
slices using immunofluorescence and
again we got the same result the other
question we asked was are we seeing
cancer stem cells and as I mentioned you
could see perhaps a continuum of
stemness in the tumor or you could see
bimodal distribution we found something
in between okay so just like we had an
EMT score we have a stemness score which
is a composite of the expression levels
of well known cancer stem cell markers
and also some embryonic stem cell
markers so this is the histogram or
distribution of stemness scores for red
tumor cells and blue normal cells so we
don't see something bimodal we see
something more or less continuous but we
see a tail that I've circled in green of
10 tumor epithelial cells that really
have outlier stemless scores compared to
the normal epithelial cells and so this
is quite promising they of course
expressed some of the known stemness
markers that's how we identified them
but they also expressed some new markers
and we scaling the cell to see what
those markers are exactly so then I
alluded to the fact that bulk
differential expression could be
misleading because the cellular
proportions are different between tumor
normals so if you do tumor normal
differential expression what this Venn
diagram shows is that a lot of cell type
specific genes show up in your bulk
differential show up as bulk
differentially expressed genes in large
cohorts and the green circle on the top
left is the true single cell tumor
normal differentially expressed genes
they also show up in your birth data but
actually the cell type-specific genes
which have to some extent artifacts also
show up and that's a challenge I should
say also we have not detected a very
large number of differentially expressed
genes in single cell and that's because
this is just a first pass we had only a
few hundred tumor cells and scaling up
and then we'll have a more complete
companion of tumor specific cell
type-specific up regulation and down
regulation
so again it's possible I mean you can
never rule out that even a single cell
differential expression is misleading
again because of dissociation artifacts
or something like that so for all our
major conclusions on EMT stemless and in
this case what I'm showing is tgf-beta
signaling we like to use tissue sections
and visualize them and see that even in
the relatively intact tissue our
conclusions are robust so what I'm
showing here is that we had a conclusion
from single-cell analysis that it was
the caps the cancer associated
fibroblasts that was secreting tgf-beta
and the epithelial cells in a tumor were
responding to need tgf-beta and we're
looking at this of course because
tgf-beta signaling is a known risk
factor in colorectal cancer and
correlated with poor survival so the
rightmost panel you see is on the top is
human stroma I should specifically two
more claps two more fibroblasts and the
little red dots I hope you can see them
in their TG beta molecules you don't see
so many so many little red dots in the
top middle panel and that's because TJ
beta is Sigma and those are epithelial
cells so TJ Beta Sigma secreted by
fibroblast cells and then signals to the
epithelial cells and we've seen that in
this tissue section so then the next
question we ask is can we actually tell
the clinician anything that they did not
know there beforehand specifically can
we stratify patients right we don't have
a large enough cohort we have only 11
patients right now so instead of trying
to start to stratify those 11 patients
we thought we'll use our single cell
signatures to stratify patients in
public databases or bulk transcriptomes
and here you you see the TCGA cohort and
another cohort as well on the right-hand
side to cut a long story short we use a
single cell signatures to classify bulk
transcriptomes into three classes here
the light blue class the dark blue class
and the maroon class and then you see
the survival plots so
patience from these three classes and
you can see here that in both cohorts
with the light blue patients had better
survival and this is statistically
significant then the dark blue and
maroon cohorts indicating that our
single-cell transcriptomes can inform
public by transcriptome databases and
you know specifically this light blue
cohort of the sign cohort has a lower
fibroblast signature and that is again
known to be correlated with good
survival it also has a lower myeloid
signature and there's some debate about
whether whether macrophages are
protective or harmful in colorectal
cancer but in this case clearly our data
are showing that the tumors with the
lowest myeloid signature lowest
macrophage signature have better
survival so there are already bulk
transcriptome based classification of
tier patients by survival so we said can
we improve on that and what you see here
the two columns are two bulk
transcriptome subtypes the intra site
like subtype and the goblet like subtype
we found sub subtypes using a single
cell transcriptome stir we found our
dark blue sub subtype and a light blue
sub sub pack and I told you already the
light blue type is has better prognosis
and indeed our bulk transcriptome
classes had subclasses with
significantly different survival so
we're very excited about expanding on
this approach so to summarize the tumor
analysis we use normal novel competition
algorithms for normalizing clustering
the cells and finding differentially
expressed genes and using these
algorithms we were able to identify cell
types in an unbiased way from
single-cell RNA seek data
we can't always take bulk tumor-normal
differentially expressed genes at face
value though of course they are valuable
for collaboration the tumor epithelium
looks more stem like on average and then
there is a small population maybe about
four percent of us tumor cells that look
like outliers are very high stemless and
we're investigating that further we
don't see transcriptomic evidence of EMT
actually the EMT markers are pretty
lated in fiberglass in our data and in
one previous study as well this does not
mean empty doesn't happen but it does
suggest that at least in these tumors
it's not widespread and we validated
this using immunofluorescence as well
and lastly single-cell expression
signatures can be used to predict
patient's survival even when you're
starting with bulk transcriptome data
and projecting it onto single-cell data
so we think there's a lot of promise for
this method simply because it's more
high-resolution so I'd like to thank the
people who did all the work so Elise
Cora on the left
did all of the experimental work for the
tumor analysis aided by uliana tan
the mother Ryan did the mouse brain
single-cell RNA seek work
aided by Michele de Baca Sengupta
created the algorithms for normalization
and differential expression openly
created the algorithm the RC algorithm
for clustering and did all of the data
analysis for the colorectal cancer data
and I'd like to thank my collaborators
as well Paul Robson who was my former
colleague set up the single-cell
facility here and drove the created a
single cell tumor pipeline and Ian Town
is a medical oncologist specialized in
colorectal cancer working with us on the
interpretation and my funding agencies
as well thank you well thank you so very
much doctor for that amazing and
informative presentation hey before we
get started on today's question in
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them
and the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and with time allowed we're gonna try to
answer as many questions as we possibly
can
um so dr. our first question is is what
factors should be considered if
interested in analyzing transcripts that
are not single cell copy example line 1
sign 1 elements
well express express their own
transposons so you know it would be
interesting to study harder in tracking
and perhaps even influencing tumor
biology that's it we have not analyzed
lines and science ourselves as the
question implies they're all homologous
to each other so it'll be very hard to
tell them apart I would see if you want
to do it do it with long read paired end
so you can start to tell them apart at
least the slightly older lines and signs
you see you can distinguish one copy and
other from another with long reads
they're really recent line one
insertions for example I don't think you
can tell them apart yeah I'm afraid I
can't address that question too much
because we have not done this analysis
ourselves thank you so very much our
next question is going to be recent
publications from rusty
gauge suggests that ploidy is frequent
in normal brains how does this parameter
a variable ploidy evaluate an analysis
Soames to have different copy number
certainly in cancer cell lines and you
know you know fragments can also be
variable in solid tumors there have been
some algorithms that can by informatica
ly infer structural variation in copy
number variation from single cell on EC
data in our dataset and we were able to
reproduce that on public data from Aviv
Regev lab in our data we're not able to
tell the structural variations apart
using the single cell RNA seek data so I
would say you want income complimentary
ideally that you don't want to be doing
it you want to have some DNA sequencing
data as well there are exciting
technologies now that can profile DNA
and RNA from the same cell and I think
that that it will really be essential or
sequencing DNA and RNA from the same
cell that would be really essential for
understanding structural variation and
how it influences the transcriptome so
in fact at least go to our has just my
postdoc I just published a paper on that
and not you know DNA and RNA sequencing
and many other people have published
that as well alright and thank you in
examining solid tumors the same concern
applies regarding ploidy
if the tumor chromosomal ploidy changes
how does one separate out transcript
changes due to this issue rather than
changes the transcriptional regulations
alright I'll move on to the next
question which which I guess is how do
you know the emt score of two more
fiberglass is really from fibroblast
that's an excellent question so as I
said we clustered cells by transcriptome
and the cells that we are calling
fibroblast there they have they look
identical at the marker level or very
similar marker Levitan all the
fibroblast the ones that we are calling
it teal look very similar at the marker
level to normal epithelial cells also in
the RNA seek reads the cells that we
call in epithelial we see somatic
variants in both there are any secrets
the cells we calling fibroblasts we
don't see somatic mutations and there
are any secrets even though you know
there is ample coverage at some low side
there's a lot of reads covering that
somatic variant but we do we see only
the wild-type version so there that's
our evidence that it's somatic variant
so sorry that's a fiberglass and not an
epithelial cell all right
thank you so very much here and it's a
stage for CRC tumor have more fibroblast
cells than the high EMT scores than the
lower stages one that's a good question
we do expect to see variability from
tomo to tomo to be frank I don't
remember what result we got I remember
the result we got from the cancer cancer
stimulus heterogeneity yeah I'm I'm
guessing we would have seen some
fiberglass heterogeneity as well but
yeah we wouldn't have to look at that I
would say we really need more data we
don't have a whole lot of fibroblast
cells from this data set and actually
the dissociation protocol matters as
well we found that when we change the
dissociation protocol subtly we get more
fiberglass and we're doing that right
now to expand our fibroblast dataset all
right thank you and there are several
approaches to single-cell
transcriptional analysis but most can be
categorized as either end or tag
counting a full-length analysis why do
you choose to use full-length analysis
and why do you think it gained from
taking this approach instead of the end
counting method sure so I think both
methods have their advantages so within
counting and um I is a unique molecular
identifier you can potentially reduce
the amount of noise or of course the
noise also depends on the quality of
your data in our case we liked the full
length because we were able to cover
somatic variants for the RNA seek reads
so we could to some extent detect
somatic variants and as I mentioned in
the case of EMT that was really
important
for us if we have separate DNA
sequencing from the same cells
perhaps in counting would not make us
lose so much but still them we hope to
analyze splicing as well from the
full-length single-cell RNA see data
it's not we won't get all of the
isoforms because these datasets have a 3
prime bias but we will get hopefully the
3 prime isoforms or 3 3 prime splicing
variation all right thank you so very
much dr. do you have any final comments
for us on today to take away from your
presentation all right so I close to the
end just a very brief final comment this
was just our first project and solid
team analysis with single-cell RNA seek
I think it's extremely promising at
least from our perspective and we
scaling up in many different directions
we want to look at biomarkers we want to
look at tumor immunology we're looking
at lung cancer as well we want to see
how these tumors respond to drugs and so
on so there's many directions we can
take this and also you want to scale up
to have more cells or tumor correct
thank you so very much doctor for your
wonderful presentation again and thank
you for your time and thank you to the
audience as well for all of your
intriguing questions I would also like
to thank our font sponsor fluid I'm for
making today's educational webcasts
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
January 2017 and you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
can invite you to forward this
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye
you